Петро їм до депутатів і замовив його з так
званої безвізового пакету було на стиль
ківа жив його для української влади.
ікло від сторонніх у братів до
голосування Верховну Раду проїхав
прем'єр-міністр арсеній яценюк вона ширяє
про їх дані згорнувся президент Петро
порошенка я за кликаю народних у братів
за собою виявить паве дальністю
постарайтеся і такі місії, бо частка
безвізового режиму абсолютно ваших руках
шановний депутат
диск на депутатів за неї свої плоди 3
закон з так званого безвізового пакету
хвали лукашем вчить вони і ще один закон
про за зовнішньою трудовою міграцією юпітер
та малих тіла муур мова що документи
може на стежки ти на виду порядку
даного
експерти знають, щоб депутат витягає
впала ним на південь відомих рішень, але нас
правді
шлюб політичної волі там уже ці закони
не косметичні для української
політичної та правової системи в
Америці мови та каріна змінити його
небагато кому порушити комфорт жити, а він
і роботу промов
безпритульними там та раніше була тінь у
адже темно і успіхи на їжу стад ним і за
Криму депутати провалили поправку до
проекту нового трудового кодексу якоб
завоняло дискримінацію сексуальних
меншин шинам навику але воші одну з
ключових в міг з уіллемом вони процесу
реформу кіно для безвізового режиму ним
набряки експерти у велика дільничними
побачилися брюсселя я думаю тут пан
юнкер припустився допоміг йому там ще за
рану сказав сем уже 100 тис а в ж на
при кінсі руку за моїми речами писати
його воля до реформ кукаїв змінилося в
роті було з барі нотацій диск і чи треба
тієї години для роботи над у милками у
верховної ради практично травня
за словами порошенка не активна у стик
ну ти впав і ти всі закони дуб an ideal
до дев'ятого та листопада inox та безвізового
режиму в'їзд і буду